روح انخفض مستوى المياه في هذه البركه
الواقعه في منطقه كان ماران شماليه محافظه
السليمانيه خلال عام واحد فقط نحو مترين
ما جعلها مرتاعا للطحالب والتلوث
خالد الذي لا يعرف مهنه اخرى منذ نحو
عقدين وتربيه الجواميس ماذا يفكر في
التخلي عنها
الجاموس في السنوات السابقه كان عدد
الجواميس كبيرا كنت املك وحدي اكثر من 180
راسها لكننا توالي سنوات
جعل الامر صعبه
ومع توالي سنوات الجفاف وارتفاع وتيره
التصحر وقله مياه الانهار القادمه من دول
الجوار فان وجود الجواميس بات مهددا في
انحاء البلاد
والمحصله انخفاض عدد الجواميس الى النصف
تقريبا في اقليم كردستان وحده
هنا يحتوي حليب البقر على اربعه في المئه
من الدهون بينما تتضاعف النسبه في حليب
الجاموس ولذلك يزيد الطالب عليه لكن
الارتفاع سعر اربك المعادله خصوصا مع قله
العرض بسبب نقص الراهن في اعداد الجواميس
مئات العائلات تعيش من هذا القطاع بين
مربينا لها وصانعين وبائعين لمنتجاتها لكن
الوضع بدا يسوء
ويبقى الوضع صعبا على مربي الجواميس بعدما
كانت اعداد وفي اقليم كردستان تقدر بعشرات
الالاف ها هي اليوم تتناقص بوتيره متسارعه
بحيث باتت لا تتجاوز المئه امير فندي
الجزيره السليمانيه